cientos de manifestantes ocupan el
parlamento de irak normalmente la zona
verde de bagdad donde se encuentran los
edificios gubernamentales y embajadas
está fuertemente protegida pero los
muros de hormigón y las fuerzas armadas
no evitaron que los manifestantes
allanaron la explanada convocados por el
clérigo chiíta moqtada al sádr
estamos aquí como manifestantes en la
casa del pueblo los políticos no
representan al pueblo su legitimidad
está obsoleta termino
las protestas revelan la división entre
las fuerzas chiítas del país los
seguidores de 'la cedar están
determinados a continuar con la
ocupación que empezó el sábado fue la
segunda vez en una semana que se tomaron
la sede protestan contra el bloque rival
del clérigo la coalición chiíta hyatt al
shabab y apoyada por irán que nominó al
exministro de trabajo mohammed zia al
sudaní para el puesto de primer ministro
la formación de al sadar fue la que ganó
más escaños en las elecciones del pasado
año pero los ministros fieles al clérigo
renunciaron en masa en junio lo que dio
la oposición más fuerza en el parlamento
el domingo el líder chiíta alabó las
protestas a través de 'twitter'
calificándolas de una oportunidad
extraordinaria para un cambio esencial
del sistema político los manifestantes
piden nuevas elecciones y el reemplazo
de los magistrados de la corte suprema
que tienen una mora ya estamos aquí
seguimos que era sr
algunos de los opositores de al sadar
llaman al diálogo pero de momento la
política iraquí continúa bloqueada tras
diez meses sin gobierno electo